hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast disrupting sexually
transmitted diseases by leveraging
innovative technologies or prevention an
overview of global and local STD trends
and impact presented by dr. Joan Chow
chief of surveillance epidemiology
assessment and evaluation section of the
sexually transmitted disease control
branch at the California Department of
Public Health
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab rats and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen our speaker will
also respond to your questions via email
if you any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
educational credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining those credits
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter dr. Joan Chow I will now turn
the presentation over to her welcome dr.
Chou thank you dr. Valdes I am very
honored to be invited by lab roots to
speak on today's topic here are my
disclosures with regard to conflicts of
interest and sources of funding I have
none to disclose the findings and
conclusions in this presentation are my
own and do not represent the official
position of the California Department of
Public Health STD control branch the
learning objectives for today's talk are
as follows
first to describe global and local
trends and bacterial sexually
transmitted to diseases also known as
STDs and priority populations at risk
for them to discuss gaps and access to
effective STD prevention strategies and
third describe innovative technologies
and policies that can improve access to
STD screening and diagnosis and
ultimately disrupt STDs here's an
overview for how I would like to achieve
those learning objectives I wanted to
start with an orientation as to why STD
control programs are an important
component of STD prevention on a
population level and describe the
functional framework for how these
programs implement prevention the
majority of the talk Averell will cover
both global and local STD trends through
2017 and how the epidemiology informs
our prevention priorities I'll be
focusing on the bacterial STDs syphilis
congenital syphilis gonorrhea and
chlamydia I'll finish with a summary of
STD prevention priorities as well as
innovative solutions and potential
partnerships to adjust those priorities
so why are STDs a major public health
priority for prevention this map from
the world World Health Organization
shows the burden of curable bacterial
STDs as of 2016 which include chlamydia
gonorrhea syphilis and trichomoniasis as
you can see the burden is huge across
continents from anywhere of 18 million
STDs up to a hundred and forty two
million STDs are also a major prevention
priority in the United States as they
are the most commonly reported condition
the latest data released by the US
Centers for Disease Control for 2016
reflect the third straight year of
increases for the three reportable
bacterial conditions chlamydia gonorrhea
and syphilis for chlamydia there were
over one-and-a-half million cases with a
five percent increase in rates since
2015 gonorrhea is nearly half a million
cases and a reflecting a 20
cent rate increase since 2015 and for
primary and secondary syphilis with over
27,000 cases also reflecting a 20%
increase since 2015 and perhaps very
concerning Lee an increase now in
congenital syphilis up to 600 over 600
cases a major increase of over 25
percent since 2015
however these reported cases are just
the tip of the iceberg Satterwhite and
colleagues from the CDC estimated that
back in 2008 there were already an
estimated 20 million new bacterial and
viral STDs with nearly 50 percent having
been acquired by young men and women
aged 15 to 24 most of these infections
are asymptomatic and have the potential
to cause adverse reproductive outcomes
such as infertility neonatal
complications and death an increased
risk for acquiring or transmitting human
immunodeficiency virus or HIV here again
we see a public media report from The
Economist about why STDs are on the rise
in in America and again has garnered the
attention of public health and the
government in particular looking more
locally at California which has a
population of 35 million we see the same
pattern as nationally where not only are
STDs the most commonly reported well
conditioned but trans have also been
increasing here are the trends for the
three major reportable bacterial STDs in
California shown here with chlamydia and
green gonorrhea in red and early
syphilis which combines primary and
secondary and early latent syphilis in
blue from 1990 to 2017 based on reports
to date and we see that chlamydia rates
as of 2017 in the green curve at the top
have risen since 1996 to their highest
level at over two hundred and eighteen
thousand reported cases our highest
volume since reporting began in 1990
when we look at gonorrhea in the red
curve we also see that gonorrhea burden
has risen to higher than even 1990
levels with over 75 thousand cases and
although early syphilis cases were at a
lower volume by orders of magnitude
compared to chlamydia and gonorrhea
during this period we have also seen
consistent and steady rises starting
from 2000 to now over 13,000 cases so
what can we do where and how can public
health and specifically STD control
programs intervene to address this large
and increasing burden of STDs this is a
schematic from the w-h-o global health
sector strategy on sexually transmitted
infections from 2016 to 2021 towards
ending SG is starting from the left you
can follow the continuum of STD services
that are needed for effective control in
a population starting from all people
who happen to be at risk to those who
are reached by primary prevention
activities through to access to care and
which includes being tested and treated
but what I just showed you is really
part of a much more coordinated set of
STD prevention activities that are
organized according to these key areas
the schematic that I'm presenting here
is for the California State STD control
branch but the framework is common
across all STD prevention programs at
local and global levels depending on
available resources so starting from the
upper left is surveillance in
Epidemiology where data on STD burden is
monitored and analyzed to describe the
demographic and behavioral
characteristics of persons at risk for
STDs going to the upper right is health
promotion to health care quality
improvement which deals with adherence
to best practices in clinical and
laboratory settings for screening
diagnosis and treatment next below is
local capacity building which enables
access to technical assistance and
training for local health department
staff to actually implement STD control
activities and the moving to the left of
that is disease intervention which is
about addressing sexual partner networks
to ensure testing and treatment to
interrupt transit
and at the bottom is medical and
scientific affairs which ensures that
prevention measures are evidence-based
and can be translated to public health
practice and lastly policy and
communications are core to identifying
addressing structural changes that are
necessary for supporting effective
prevention strategies whether through
regulations change or insurance of
access to sexual health services for
each of the following natural STDs I
will discuss where this framework can be
used to identify effective prevention
strategies let's start with syphilis
which as noted here can have very
serious complications which when left
untreated can ultimately lead to
neurosyphilis ocular and otic syphilis
and congenital syphilis and stillbirth
for babies who are exposed in utero
globally after many years of low
syphilis rates almost to the point of
elimination there has been a resurgence
that has disproportionately impacted men
who have sex with men also referred to
as MSM this review by a bar and
colleagues summarized the increases in
syphilis infections among MSM in the US
and as well as multiple countries in
Western Europe from 1998 the period with
the fewest syphilis infections onwards
through 2013 in the u.s. there was a
market increase in primary and secondary
syphilis the symptomatic stages of
syphilis that started essentially at the
same time at the in the global era in
the early 2000s and here the increases
we're seeing across all reasons of the
US and have accelerated with about a 20%
increase as of 2016 in California the
same increases have been seen here since
2003 2017 early syphilis cases in
California were predominantly male shown
here in blue with near doubling of cases
and rate of nearly 60 per thousand a
hundred thousand since 2013 as
here however we should note that female
cases and rates seen here in the red
have increased Eightfold more recently
since 20 since 2013 - a rate of 8.5
400,000 reflecting a more recent rise in
heterosexual syphilis transmission and
I'll come back to this recent trend as
well here we see a further breakdown of
2017 early syphilis cases in California
by sex and gender of sex partners and
starting from the left side of the chart
we see that 28% of early syphilis cases
were HIV positive men having sex with
men 32% of early syphilis cases were HIV
negative MSM 27% of early syphilis cases
were men having sex with men or men with
unknown gender of sex partners and last
13% were females and given this this
profile of early syphilis cases there
are clear prevention opportunities for
instance for ensuring linkage to care
for HIV positive MSM syphilis cases and
navigation to prep or pre exposure
prophylaxis for HIV negative MSM early
syphilis cases clearly there is a need
for increasing HIV testing for syphilis
cases with unknown HIV status regardless
what might be factors that have
contributed to syphilis increases among
men having sex with men well here we see
trends and specific venues for meeting
sex partners as reported in syphilis
case interviews among MSM early syphilis
cases internet or mobile apps are shown
in blue bars and clubs shown in orange
and bath houses and sex clubs are shown
in gray since 2007 the use of the
internet including mobile apps based on
geo-locating functionality has been the
most commonly reported venue among MSM
early syphilis cases more so than bars
and clubs bathhouses and sex clubs
looking at the Internet venues and apps
more closely for meeting partners
we see that Grindr has been the most
common internet venue or mobile app for
finding partners and increases in its
use has been frequently cited as a
reason for syphilis increases among all
interviewed early syphilis cases the
percent reporting meeting partners
online or via apps was 32 percent among
men having sex with men and bisexual men
as compared to heterosexual men having
sex with women only six percent and only
three and a half percent among females
in California syphilis and HIV
co-infection rates are high therefore
ensuring HIV testing of individuals with
an STD in general is a standard of care
and STD prevention and control this
particular national program outcome
measure is used to analyze new HIV
testing of syphilis cases initiated for
local health jurisdiction follow-up and
the associated new HIV positivity
associated with that testing and these
data are critical for improving linkage
to HIV care for newly HIV infected
individuals and to prep for those who
are HIV negative and you can see here on
the right then in the California project
area and in San Francisco a little over
half of early syphilis cases who are
eligible actually receive HIV testing
pretty consistently though where HIV
testing does occur the yields are high
about six to seven percent HIV
positivity in California and San
Francisco thus making a very clear case
for the cost-effectiveness of HIV
testing among syphilis cases conversely
what about syphilis screening among HIV
clients we also know that HIV care
clients are at risk for syphilis and
therefore there are national
recommendations as well for syphilis
screening among MSM clients and HIV care
per the CDC
this chart shows variation by city and
state in the proportion of MSM and HIV
care settings that were screened for
syphilis and the California project area
is shown here at the lower end at
42% so clearly a gap there so how can
STD programs use this type of
information about early syphilis cases
and can we leverage the internet and
mobile apps for instance to increase STD
HIV testing and I think the answer is is
increasingly yes for instance Grindr the
mobile app that I referred to as being
the most common one used and cited has
launched new a new opt-in HIV testing
reminder to app users to so that they
can get tested more regularly per
national guidelines and further they are
promoting this opt-in HIV testing
reminder to their over 3.6 million users
to enable them to find HIV testing sites
in the US by networking with over 200
LGBTQ community based organizations
however I do want to go back to the
other concerning increase in syphilis
that we saw for women in California
where the early syphilis rate increased
seven times during the last five years
we have also been seeing recent
increases in heterosexual syphilis
globally as well here is a recent report
from Japan where civil look similar
increases have been seen among women
starting from 2013 to 2017 when record
levels have been observed and this is in
a population where syphilis has been
relatively uncommon for many years
looking at US data for primary and
secondary syphilis among women of
reproductive age the highest increases
are also particularly concerning as you
can see here when comparing across all
of the different age groups for women
this infographic shows the connection
between syphilis increases among women
and increases in congenital syphilis
which also rose and this time by 28
percent in 2015 to 2016 in the United
States in 2007 the World Health
Organization launched the global
elimination of congenital syphilis
initiative with a goal of reducing
mother-to-child transmission of syphilis
to a sufficiently low level that's
congenital syphilis was no longer a
public health problem the goal was for
countries to achieve a congenital
syphilis rate of 50 or fewer cases per
hundred thousand live births through
achieving a programmatic targets of more
than 95% syphilis screening coverage in
pregnancy and more than 95% treatment of
women who were seropositive and in this
chart each paragraph of bars shows the
contribution of different regions in the
world to the decreases that have been
observed since 2007 and stillbirth
preterm low birth weight neonatal deaths
and syphilis infected infants this
5-year update found a 38 percent
reduction in the number of pregnant
women with syphilis and in the number of
congenital syphilis cases so definitely
in effect as a result of major efforts
to achieve those targets for prenatal
screening
however internationally congenital
syphilis still accounts for almost
200,000 perinatal deaths each year so
there's still work to be done looking
locally at California data we see the
same concerning increases in early
syphilis rates among women of
reproductive age which have increased
fourfold since 2013 this chart shows the
consequences for increases in California
female early syphilis rates on
congenital syphilis in this chart trends
in early syphilis rates among females of
childbearing age are shown by the black
line curve and congenital syphilis cases
are shown in yellow bars this increasing
trend in both female and congenital
syphilis rates has been apparent since
2012 when both conditions were at their
lowest point congenital syphilis cases
rose from a low of 33 cases in 2012 for
a fifth straight year to a provisional
level of 278 cases in 2017 an Eightfold
increase still births trends amongst the
congenital syphilis cases have also
increased and the numbers have tripled
from
12 and 2016 236 and 2017 the Centers for
Disease Control in the United States
recognized that recent persistent trends
affecting both males females and now
babies required a much more coordinated
and robust response you should be aware
that in 2017 the CDC released a CDC
call-to-action document outlining
recommended strategies reinforcing
screening treatment and partner services
for priority populations including women
of childbearing age I focused here on
the right on the specific call for
University and Industry collaboration to
develop and bring to market novel
syphilis tests and to conduct clinical
research to assess the performance of
these tests for effective prevention
this slide takes the gaps in STD
prevention for syphilis and offers some
innovative solutions for syphilis
control based on the EPI trends that we
were just reviewing improving syphilis
screening certainly is a priority for
prenatal patients and hiv-positive MSM
and the solutions that might be
considered include for instance
multiplex testing combining for instant
syphilis with HIV and potentially
hepatitis C virus it's important that
through the development of such testing
that we also potentially improve the
specificity of diagnosis of primary
lesions by adding Treponema primers
potentially say to herpes simplex virus
assays point-of-care testing is a
priority as well for increasing access
to screening perhaps it's possible to
develop a effective sensitive and
specific combined non Treponema and
troponin we'll confirmatory tests in the
same test platform in developing these
point-of-care tests it's important to
consider what the field conditions might
pose as a barrier and how to address
them through temperature requirements
and reagent stability issues and
and lastly point-of-care testing could
be further facilitated by considering
what might be the certification and
training that might be needed for
disease intervention specialists and
non-medical staff so as to be able to
conduct point-of-care tests in the field
where it's easier to actually reach
at-risk populations let's now turn to
gonorrhea trends gonorrhea prevention is
a national priority because gonorrhea
has grown resistant to nearly every drug
ever used to treat it we are now down to
one recommended treatment for gonorrhea
and we know that increasing
multidrug-resistant Neisseria gonorrhea
reports are a major concern for ongoing
control the World Health Organization
Global gonococcal and microbial
surveillance program or gas is key to
monitoring and microbial resistance
trends identifying emerging resistance
and informing regular refinements of
treatment guidelines and public health
policy on a global basis in vitro and
clinical resistance to Neisseria
gonorrhea to the extended spectrum
cephalosporins
the last line treatment for gonorrhea
have been report reported from many
particularly well resourced settings
globally with as high as 30 percent
shown here in the gold regions and up to
50 percent 50 percent shown in yellow
button sorry up to five percent is shown
in yellow the emergence of antibiotic
resistant gonorrhea especially
concerning given recent trends in
gonorrhea incidents after decades of
major declines in gonorrhea since the
1970s and low rates in the last 10 years
we have started to see recent increases
in 2016 a total of almost 500,000 cases
of gonorrhea were reported in the United
States and represented a nearly 20
percent increase since the prior year
2015 and a 50 percent increase since the
historic low in 2009
let's turning to California local trends
here we show the annual trend in
California since 1990 and you can see
again the dramatic increases after the
mid 90s with with increases particularly
for males gonorrhea cases and rates
increased by 17% over 2016 gonorrhea
cases and nearly doubled since 2013
similar to the syphilis case profile we
are starting to see an imbalance in the
gender ratios for gonorrhea about
two-thirds of our gonorrhea cases in
California are males
men who have sex with men make up 43
percent of our total cases but if you
just consider it out of just men they
make up nearly two-thirds of all male
cases and this is based on some follow
up gonorrhea cases in a project we call
the California gonorrhea surveillance
project where our gonorrhea case is
likely to be diagnosed we use the same
data from CG SS to look at providers
diagnosing men having sex with men
heterosexual men and females and noted
some key differences in the provider
type STD clinics and private providers
were the most frequent provider type for
diagnosing MSM gonorrhea case cases
while private providers and emergency
room were most common for heterosexual
men and family planning was the most
common or for females here we see the
distribution of site of infection for
gonorrhea cases by sexual orientation
how does this inform our intervention
and prevention strategies well it shows
that since half of all reported
infections were at extra general sites
for MSM screening MSM at these sites
these three sites is necessary to not
miss half or more of gonorrhea
infections as shown on the last slide
many MSM gonorrhea cases were diagnosed
at sge clinics and as such conducting
three site testing more free
currently than other providers how did
the recommendations to conduct three
Titans three site testing affect our
development of diagnostic tools well our
program in California conducts a
Clinical Laboratory survey every few
years and these data have been useful
for understanding laboratory testing of
each of the STDs and here we see the
trends for gonorrhea test sites where
the Green Line shows the increase in the
use of nucleic acid amplification tests
for GC during the 2000s where has been
the most common test type as of 2012 the
higher sensitivity of nucleic acid
amplification test for GC extra general
testing compared to culture has clearly
improved our ability to diagnose and
treat these otherwise undetected
infections adherence to three site
testing may well be a factor in for
increase gonorrhea case reporting
particularly in urban areas in
California in San Francisco and Los
Angeles in contrast to the increase in
nucleic acid amplification test
gonorrhea culture in blue has declined
dramatically from about noe half of
gonorrhea tests to less than value
percent of all gonorrhea tests so what
are the implications for understanding
trends in gonorrhea and my critical of
susceptibility trends a concerning issue
that we started this section with well
as with the w-h-o global surveillance
efforts related to any microbial
resistance the US Centers for Disease
Control has also been monitoring
gonorrhea antimicrobial resistant
patterns via a multi-site network of STD
clinics which submit 25 isolates per
month for a microbial susceptibility
testing at local public health
laboratories and CDC in this map shows
where these sites are located as noted
earlier we are down to the last
antibiotic class with cephalosporins for
gonorrhea treatment which consists of
dual therapy with a ceftriaxone
injection and as Ephram Ison and here we
see the annual trends and the percent of
gonorrhea isolates with m.i.c alert
values
associated with decreased susceptibility
from 1992 to 2017 the orange portion of
the bars indicate cefixime and the red
bar indicates ceftriaxone so fixing is
no longer recommended as a first-line
treatment increases in mi see alert
values for 616 resulted in changes in
treatment recommendations take-home
points here are that the percent of
isolates with alert values is declining
an encouraging sign and that there have
been no treatment failures in the United
States however there have been reports
of gonorrhea cases in Japan and most
recently in the United Kingdom that have
required much much higher doses of
ceftriaxone enhanced international
collaborative actions are crucial for
the control of gonorrhea and which
involve improved prevention early
diagnosis development of accurate rapid
point-of-care tests for instance partner
management and enhanced surveillance
including population based surveillance
and surveillance of treatment failures
and and microbial use rapid accurate
point of care diagnostic tests which
would ideally predict antimicrobial
resistance and/or antimicrobial
susceptibility new therapeutic drugs and
a gonococcal vaccine ultimately would be
the only sustainable way to a.g achieve
gonorrhea control so what are some STD
program gaps and innovative solutions
for gonorrhea control well one it would
be really helpful to have FDA clearance
for extra general specimens thereby
increasing the practice of three site
testing secondly enhanced international
collaborative actions are crucial for
the control of gonorrhea
including these improved prevention
strategies early diagnosis point partner
management and hand surveillance as I
mentioned and thirdly development of
rapid accurate point of care diagnostic
tests which would ideally also predict a
microbial resistance would be helpful
along with those new therapeutic drugs
and a vaccine
here is an example of how our academic
partners are developing diagnostic
solutions along these lines that can
help us treat gonorrhea infections with
appropriate antibiotics university of
california los angeles researchers
developed a real-time reverse
transcription PCR for a mutation in one
of the markers associated with
resistance for gonorrhea and this
particular test
apparently reliably predicts resistance
to ciprofloxacin you might remember
ciprofloxacin was a drug that was
associated with a high proportion of
isolates with decreased susceptibility
in the early 2000s and this innovative
test actually takes a short amount of
time anywhere from 24 to 48 hours but
it's not FDA approved and but it has
been validated in accordance with CLIA
requirements so the reason why this is
important is because then if it turns
out that the test indicates that the the
infection is susceptible to
ciprofloxacin we can actually consider
using ciprofloxacin for for treatment of
that infection now let's look at
chlamydia trends in 2016 a total of 1.6
million chlamydia infections were
reported to the US Centers for Disease
Control and has been the most commonly
reported communicable to condition since
reporting was initiated during 2015 and
2016 the overall rate increased almost
5% for the United States in 2016 the
rate however amongst women was 2 times
the rate in men and this is probably
likely to the much more common practice
of access to care for women compared to
men however during 2012 to 2016 the rate
and men also increased increased over
25%
comparison to only 1/3 3% increase
amongst amongst women and this may be
again related to increased testing for
men during the same period particularly
based on urine specimens chlamydia
remains the most commonly reported SGA
in California there were over 200,000
chlamydia cases in 2017 again the
highest volume since reporting began in
1990 likely as a result of increased
screening of young women / national
recommendations chlamydia cases in
California increased by 10% over 2016
cases and increased by 30% since 2013
and all and although female rates remain
considerably higher than males male
rates have been risen as well at an
increasing rate in the past five years
likely because an increased screening of
partners as through urine testing as
well as extra general screening as with
gonorrhea most all chlamydia tests are
nucleic acid amplification tests due to
the ability to test for both in one
specimen and as we saw with gonorrhea
the most common tests have been nucleic
acid amplification test for over many
years now and you see a corresponding
decrease in the proportion of tests that
were based on DNA probes as well as with
culture here we see consistently
increasing trends in both national and
local program rates of chlamydia
screening for young women which may
account again for the increases in
chlamydia that we've seen in the in the
previous slides
whoever gaps in screening remain
national numbers are similar to local
numbers in California across different
types of provider types whether managed
care or in public sector health program
serving women and in many cases still we
are missing half of eligible women
for me to be screened further
rescreening to prevent repeat screening
of to prevent repeat community and
gonorrhea infection is also critical for
prevention of adverse reproductive
consequences such as public and Pharma
toward disease and infertility and here
we see an additional case for why
rescreening is important
repeat positivity can be as high as 15%
for chlamydia and 10% for gonorrhea for
women who were rescreened within six
months after initial and infection here
you see different estimates for repeat
infection depending on the place the
type of data that we have either from
managed care or from family planning for
both types of repeat infection so as I
mentioned there are also gaps and
rescreening as we see here from some
data that we have on family planning
clinic patients in California only
one-third of women who were treated for
chlamydia actually where we tested
within six months of treatment but
there's another quarter of women who
actually returned to clinic but despite
that we're still not tested so indicates
some major missed opportunities for
identifying received infection for
chlamydia so here's a summary of
prevention priorities innovative
solutions and potential partnerships to
address the challenge of gaps that we've
identified based on our current
knowledge of trends and STDs and the
epidemiology first and foremost improved
access to STD and HIV testing is clearly
needed as I mentioned before FDA
clearance for a home collected vaginal
and for extra general specimens would be
an important step toward increasing
improving that at that access also rapid
CLIA waived test for non clinical
settings which include Corrections the
homeless Indian reservations or any
areas with poor access to health
including mobile clinics would be
a major major improvement with regard to
improving access and therefore control
for identifying and treating these
infections further prevalent studies to
provide evidence is important I think
for demonstrating the value from a
public health population level in terms
of screening and it's not really unclear
whether really do you need to have a
randomized control trial in order to
provide that evidence particularly for
informing US Preventive Services Task
Force and CDC treatment guidelines for
screening but clearly the the yield is
is very very high in some of these
at-risk populations and in terms of
policy issues and advocacy that can
really help us improve our ability to
control these bacterial STDs first of
all we would certainly need to have
evidence for cost-effectiveness and
return on investment we need to have
data on the cost associated with
screening and the yield as well as
understanding the extent to which we are
able to avert adverse outcomes
associated with lack of screening and
diagnosis and treatment another major
policy issue I think that affects our
ability to develop some of these
improvements and actually improve access
to these tests is what is the
reimbursement for these tests which
tests should be covered in preventive
services benefits for people accessing
care and importantly who should pay and
there are many many different payer
sources in the United States in
particular starting from the Center for
Medicare and Medicaid Services managed
care issues related to whether
capitation should cover all services as
opposed to very specific fee-for-service
costs for for STD testing so those are
just examples of some of the policy
issues and advocacy that are that are
needed both on a local as well as on a
global level
here I wanted to leave everyone with
some resources that might be helpful on
a local level that were these were
developed
during our annual STD awareness month
and these are resources that can be
found here through links to the CDC
treatment right website as well through
as well as through our own California
STD control branch website in which many
resources for providers and poor local
programs can be found reduction in
syphilis gonorrhea and possibly
chlamydia going forth is possible as
indicated by these projections if there
is a concerted effort along the lines of
the STD control program framework that I
started with the World Health
Organization is using this framework to
project a goal of 90% reduction in the
burden at least for syphilis and
gonorrhea with public and private
partnerships globally and locally I
think that it truly is possible disrupt
to disrupt STDs on the occasion of the
world sexual health day in 2017 the
w-h-o is launching a new whio framework
for operationalizing sexual health and
its linkages to reproductive health and
this model highlights the many areas
where people's sexual health must be
safeguarded through the course of their
lives as well as in the way in which
sexual health and reproductive health
are at once distinctive and yet
inextricably linked on the 4th September
every year the whu-oh department of
reproductive health and research joins
people in organizations worldwide in
celebrating world sexual health day and
the theme of this year's event is quote
love bonding and intimacy unquote to
reflect on the joyful aspects of sharing
our own sexual health and sexuality with
someone we love and/or with people we
choose very on that positive note I
wanted to thank you for your attention
thank you dr. Chow for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type those questions
into the box that appear on the screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with questions via email
so let's take a look at some of our
questions that have come in STD
screening rates do not seem to be at the
optimal level to effectively identify
and treat asymptomatic STDs so dr. Chow
what are some of the barriers that
providers face when adhering to
recommend dated oh I'm sorry I
recommended STD screening guidelines
thank you that's a great question and I
think that where one should start is
really with their training providers are
not necessarily trained in conducting
comprehensive risk assessment of their
patients and that goes to training
sometimes the the lack has to do with
having the tools to at hand in the
clinical setting for actually doing a
comprehensive risk assessment so that
they are aware of amongst whom of their
patients are sexually active
particularly adolescents and and young
adults the types of partnerships that
they have what's the gender of sex
partners there are history of condom use
and and so forth having those types of
tools in some easy to access manner
would be a major major help not having
them available I think or or having the
training I think would be a major
barrier so providing that type of
training and those tools would be a
major asset I think in terms of having
increasing those screening rates for
patients who require that that type of
screening there's some structural other
structural barriers that
that providers might be facing in the in
the clinical setting that include the
ability to collect specimens whether
urine or cervical or so forth or blood
easily and so having a clinical setting
in which those types of specimens can be
collected easily I think is another one
and so from a structural organizational
clinic flow perspective I think thinking
about how it might be easy to change
clinic flow so that providers aren't the
only dependent point in the clinic flow
to actually collect those specimens
would be really helpful there's some
pretty innovative ways to get around
some of these by changing the clinic
lower or enabling risk assessment to be
actually conducted before actually
seeing the provider so is to reduce the
burden on providers providers actually
have very little time in most cases to
see to collect this information and
collect these specimens and so reducing
those barriers those structural barriers
I think would be really important for
improving screening rates and dr. Chow
is there a cost benefit to home-based
screening or even telehealth for
confidential STD care well definitely
with the improvements the vast
improvements in some of the the
screening tests for chlamydia gonorrhea
in recent years means that there is
likely going to be increased screening
of persons who would not be accessing
care who feel that they would like to be
screened in a confidential manner so the
benefit is is clear in terms of the the
numbers of infections that have been
identified through some really
innovative home-based testing programs
that have been implemented in many areas
of the United States and so I think that
the cost of these programs associated
with home based testing I think
it can be demonstrated I think through
some systematic evaluation of
identifying to what extent would
undetected infections amongst people who
would not be accessing home-based care
would have would have resulted in
ongoing transmission of infections to
their partners and in the community the
cost associated with infections that
would have gone on to affect our general
tract such as pelvic inflammatory
disease and potentially infertility you
have to balance essentially the cost of
the benefits of implementing these
programs with the types of infections
and ongoing transmission that would have
occurred so those types of evaluations
are are still needed I think in order to
help promote home base screen in terms
of telehealth again we have to think
about you know how we're able to
actually get persons who would not
otherwise come into the clinic setting
actually accessing care and having some
of those conversations with a provider
in a telehealth environment
and and how that essentially connects
them to potentially home-based screening
for STDs thereby bringing them into to
care and treatment I haven't seen any
cost-benefit analyses of telehealth but
I think that given the increasing use of
this really innovative technology for
reaching patients I think is is going to
be a really important factor in
continuing to promote telehealth
particularly for people who want the the
confidentiality that's afforded through
a remote connection to healthcare in dr.
Chau you meet you've made a strong case
for the continued development and
utilization of the
point-of-care tests for syphilis to
increase access to screening
particularly for hard-to-reach at-risk
groups what are some of the research and
policy barriers that need to be overcome
to facilitate the use of these points of
care tests well the situations in which
point-of-care tests for syphilis have
been used has really been in small
settings and those include outbreak
settings where Trump annual point of
care test for syphilis have been very
very useful for use in the field and I
can think of Corrections being one area
in some outbreaks it's been recognized
that many of the simplest cases
associated with an outbreak have been
actually identified in jail or have
contacts who have been in jail before
so it's it's really an important
research priority is to try and get more
of such data used on a much more
population level with high-risk persons
for with regards to syphilis and I think
the more information that we have about
the high yield when used in a very
targeted way with high-risk populations
can really further inform some of these
cost analyses for for supporting
expansion of point-of-care tests for for
syphilis and and and I have to stress
that it's important to try to do these
evaluations using data where there are
high-risk persons and not just in low
prevalence populations in terms of some
of the policy barriers there are a
number of them that that need to be
addressed and and one is and I think I
refer to this in the presentation itself
and that is that there needs to be
expansion of these point-of-care tests
such that non-medical staff can actually
perform them out in the field and
outside of the clinical setting that is
and currently there are some major
restrictions on non-medical personnel
for for conducting these tests and I
think until we resolve some of those
barriers I think local public health
programs that that rely on non-medical
staff in the field to do this type of
follow-up investigation and and partner
contact tracing are going to be
hard-pressed for for being able to do
effective screening interventions in
high-risk populations so clearly we need
to think really carefully about how we
can really expand training and some of
the restrictions the regulations on
conducting these tests other barriers
have to do with some of the clear waiver
policies that again make it difficult I
think to actually implement some of
these screening tests in in the field
dr. Chow think you I want to thank you
again for your presentation today I'd
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
2018 you'll receive an email from a lab
route letting you know when the webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now and thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye bye